Nous sommes en l'an 1977.
La sonde américaine Voyager a quitté le
sol terrestre pour un périple à travers
le vide spatial.
Aujourd'hui, soit 43 ans plus tard, elle a
déjà quitté le système solaire et vogue
à 18.000 milliards de km de son berceau.
C'est désormais l'artefact d'origine humaine
le plus lointain de nous.
Et c'est surtout un témoin émouvant de la
soif de connaissances et d'exploration qui
anime l'être humain, le regard tourné vers
le ciel, vers un ailleurs porteur de tous
les fantasmes, tous les rêves, tous les espoirs.
Bon par contre, pour savoir ce qu'il y a sous
nos pieds, là y'a plus personne !
Ah bah faut dire que c'est facile de savoir
ce qu'il y a dans l'espace, dans l'assiette
d'Angelina Jolie ou dans une vidéo d'e-penser.
On regarde et on voit qu'y a rien ! Alors
que si on veut savoir ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
de la Terre, on a comme un petit souci.
C'est que Mère nature n'était pas vitrière.
Comme je me le disais en me réveillant hier
matin à 15h : si l'espace est plein de vide,
les roches, elles, sont vides de plein.
Ça veut rien dire mais ça a l'air profond,
un peu comme le forage de Kola, qu'on embrasse
(Colas, pas son forage, on n'en est pas encore
assez intimes).
Le trou le plus profond qu'on ait creusé,
12 km et des brouettes.
Il est situé en Russie.
Eh oui, c'est ce qu'ils font les Russes, ils
vont dans l'espace, ils annexent la Crimée
et ils creusent des trous.
Ce forage de Kola a été commencé en 1970,
donc avant le départ de la sonde Voyager,
même si ça n'a rien à voir, et il aura
duré près de 20 ans. 20 ans pour creuser
12 km.
A la base, ils voulaient descendre plus bas.
Mais ils avaient mal anticipé la pression
et la chaleur ainsi que la torsion sur l'axe
de forage.
Donc ils ont dû abandonner en cours de route.
Eh ouais, c'est ce qu'ils font, les Russes.
Ils abandonnent.
Ils abandonnent leurs principes en implantant
des McDo sur leur territoire, ils abandonnent
le droit à la propriété en faveur du collectivisme
et ils lynchent leurs homosexuels.
Si vous êtes Russe, j'ai qu'une chose à
vous dire : zavtrak.
Bref. 12 km c'est un record mondial.
Ils ont traversé le tiers de la croûte terrestre
! En parlant de croûtes, vous connaissez
le sport préféré des lépreux ?
Mais il reste encore plus de 6.000 km à parcourir
pour arriver au centre de la planète.
Donc comme ma mère m'a toujours dit dans
mon enfance, ça part d'une bonne intention
mais c'est pas une bonne idée de repeindre
le chat avec ton vomi.
Ou en l'occurrence, de creuser pour essayer
de savoir si la Terre renferme un cœur extra
moelleux tels les cookies Granola à l'huile
de palme.
Alors, comment faire ?
Pour commencer, on peut demander aux philosophes.
Ils en savent rien non plus mais ils pensent
toute la journée, c'est leur métier.
Et des fois, à force de réfléchir très
très fort, ils accouchent d'idées.
Alors bon, on va leur laisser une chance.
L'un des premiers à en avoir eu des idées
sur la question, en tout cas en Occident,
c'était, roulement de tambours, Aristote
!
Quand il avait fini de compter les pattes
des mouches et les dents des femmes, il s'est
mis à imaginer une espèce de théorie des
éléments.
Un peu comme les pokémon feu, herbe, paillasson,
sauce soja, groupe électrogène, je sais
pas je connais mal toutes ces fantaisies.
Donc, pour Aristote, la Terre était formée
de l'élément terre.
Et, mon cher Watson, cette couche de terre
est entourée d'eau puis d'air puis d'une
couche de feu.
C'est comme si un Salamèche avait bouffé
un Roucoule qui lui-même avait gobé un Carapuce
qui lui-même mangeait… de la terre.
C'est cette vision qui a perduré pendant
toute l'Antiquité et le Moyen-Âge en Occident.
Aristote démission.
Et puis après, bon, y'a eu des explorations,
Vasco de Gama, Magellan, Gérard Collomb,
des nouveaux paradigmes quand Copernic a dit
que la Terre, le Soleil, en fait, c'est pas
ce que vous croivez.
Et là-dessus, dans ce grand chamboulement
cosmique, notre bon René Descartes s'est
senti un peu pousser des ailes et lui aussi
il a voulu disrupter.
Nous sommes en l'an 1644.
Descartes a fini de dissocier le corps et
l'esprit mais il lui reste encore un peu de…
euh… poussière d'étoiles.
Un soir, il s'est fait un bon gros trip au
coin du feu et il s'est dit, les mecs, mais
en fait la Terre c'est un ancien soleil.
(Ouais, elle était corsée leur poussière
d'étoiles à l'époque).
Du coup, pour lui, y'a encore un vieux reste
de soleil au milieu de notre planète, puis
d'autres couches autour, notamment une couche
de terre bien tassée, une couche d'eau, une
couche d'air, re-une couche de terre moins
tassée qui flotte au-dessus de l'air comme
un hoverboard.
Mais cette couche-là est séchée par le
soleil (le vrai) et du coup elle fendille
comme dans le Roi Lion là, y'a des miettes
qui tombent au fond et alors y'a la couche
d'eau qui en profite pour remonter dans les
fissures et paf ! Ca nous fait des rivières
et des océans.
Je vous avais dit qu'ils pensaient beaucoup
les philosophes.
C'est des professionnels de la pensée.
N'essayez pas de reproduire ça chez vous.
Donc non seulement ce bon René a imaginé
la structure interne de la Terre mais en plus
il nous raconte comment elle s'est formée.
Que c'était un ancien soleil, toussa.
Et ça, c'est plutôt joli et plutôt original.
Y'a eu une tartine de modèles après, je
vous épargne les détails.
Je vais juste vous raconter mon préféré,
qui a été conçu par un certain Gautier.
Un ingénieur des Ponts et chaussées qui
a vécu au 18e siècle.
Ingénieur donc il a donc une vision pragmatique
des choses et extrêmement réaliste.
Carrée.
Donc pour lui, la Terre était creuse.
Et à l'intérieur, y'avait exactement le
même monde en symétrique, séparé de nous
par une croûte terrestre de 5 km d'épaisseur.
Soit approximativement la distance Décines-Meyzieux,
pour les Lyonnais.
Et cette couche-là est maintenue en équilibre
par deux forces opposées : la gravité et
une force qui provient de la rotation de la
Terre.
Et du coup il pourrait y avoir de la vie à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de la Terre,
un peu comme un testicule géant.
C'est pas plus enthousiasmant comme idée
qu'une crotte de nez technologique qui fait
du rodéo dans le vide interstellaire ? D'imaginer
que si ça se trouve, il y a un autre vous
qui vit sa vie en ce moment-même sous vos
pieds.
Vous avez un double souterrain.
Je me demande ce qu'il est en train de faire
en ce moment, votre double.
Et vous, qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train
de faire de votre vie à regarder une vidéo
de géologie de votre plein gré ? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? Venez vous confier dans les
commentaires.
En plus YouTube a implémenté un nouvel outil
de suggestion automatique de réponses tout
à fait au point, je m'engage solennellement
à l'utiliser dès qu'il me le proposera en
réponse à vos commentaires.
Pour finir avec cette idée de Terre creuse,
je trouve ça absolument fascinant.
Je me demande à quoi ressembleraient les
civilisations d'en-dessous, comment elles
auraient évolué dans un monde sans soleil,
quelles seraient leurs sources d'énergie,
est-ce qu'elles auraient de la lumière, la
nuit en regardant en l'air elles voient pas
la voûte étoilée qui brille comme autant
de bijoux sertis de nos fantasmes, de nos
espoirs, de nos rêves, mais juste leurs voisins
d'en face.
La vie parisienne en fait.
Bref, maintenant qu'on a un cadre théorique
solide, merci les philosophes, on va pouvoir
voir en pratique à quoi ressemble l'intérieur
de la Terre.
Et ça, on l'a appris pas en creusant parce
qu'on peut pas aller bien loin, on l'a vu,
pas non plus en coupant la planète parce
qu'on n'a pas de couteau ni de fil à beurre
assez grand… mais que font-ils au concours
Lépine quand on a besoin d'eux ? Bon, qu'est-ce
qui nous reste comme option ?
Déjà, on peut regarder des affleurements.
Parfois, quand les montagnes se plissent telle
la peau de votre sharpei quand ses fabricants
le dégonflent avant de vous le vendre pour
que ça prenne moins de place à la livraison
(Peu de propriétaires de chiens le savent
mais oui, vous êtes censés regonfler votre
sharpei quand vous le recevez, faut pas le
laisser comme ça), et donc quand les montagnes
se plissent, elles remontent en surface du
matériel issu des profondeurs, qu'on peut
observer tout gentiment en promenant son fameux
sharpei regonflé dans les Pyrénées ou les
Alpes.
C'est comme ça qu'on a appris que le manteau
terrestre était vert, parce qu'il est composé
de péridotite, une roche bourrée d'olivines.
Qu'on appelle aussi péridot.
La nature est bien faite.
Mais même si c'est déjà super, on trouvera
pas de cailloux qui proviennent de plus profond
que le manteau terrestre.
Bon, alors, comment faire ?
Ne ménageons pas le suspense plus longtemps
: on peut procéder avec la Terre comme avec
votre employée enceinte : ne pas renouveler
son CDD, et faire une échographie pour voir
ce qu'elle a dans le ventre.
Et pour faire cette échographie de la Terre,
on l'écoute vibrer.
Roh cette vidéo est vraiment poétique et
inspirante comme un film de Christophe Barbier.
Nous sommes en l'an 1970.
Le Pérou est secoué par un séisme, qui
provoque un glissement de terrain ensevelissant
littéralement un village avec ses habitants
et ses alpagas.
20.000 morts.
2004 à Sumatra, un tremblement de terre suivi
d'un tsunami tuera 230.000 âmes.
2010, une secousse à Port-au-Prince en Haïti
fera 316.000 morts.
Autant qu'il y a d'habitants à Nantes ou
à Nice.
Eh ben ça, c'est du pain béni pour les géologues
! Oui, ils ont un cœur de pierre.
Ces bons gros séismes ont produit des ondes
qui ont parcouru toute la planète.
Et elles nous permettent d'en faire cette
fameuse échographie.
Bon ça marche aussi avec les petits séismes
mais les gros produisent des ondes plus intenses
qui s'atténuent moins rapidement et qui du
coup, vont plus loin.
Et voilà, Ringo ! C'est comme ça que les
sismologues arrivent à cartographier l'intérieur
de la planète jusqu'à son centre.
Les tremblements de terre.
Mais avant d'aller plus loin, une page de
réclame.
Un impact, une fissure ? C'est du quartz !
Tu ne le portes plus ? Brûle-le !
Figurez-vous que la famille d'une amie complètement
folle (de jeux d'enquête) a lancé un financement
participatif pour un jeu que je trouve assez
cool, du coup je voulions vous en causer.
Son nom : Script.
Sa passion : les énigmes.
Son ennemi juré : les fruits.
C'est une série qui contient plusieurs collections,
la première s'intitule "Romans noirs" avec
déjà 2 enquêtes :
Mystères à Hollywoodland : A la mort de
votre grand père, vous découvrez une mystérieuse
boîte, pleine de photos, articles et documents
consacrés à sa mère, célèbre actrice
hollywoodienne des années 40.
Mais votre arrière-grand-mère cachait un
lourd secret qui vous changera à jamais…
Pour le découvrir, il vous faudra plonger
dans l'âge d'or d'Hollywood.
Ça c'est un jeu d'enquête classique en une
boîte, à faire le dimanche aprem, seul ou
avec ses amis ou sa famille si vous avez la
chance de disposer de l'un des deux.
Ce n'est pas mon cas.
Deuxième enquête, la famille Hohenburg : Le
riche industriel Johan Hohenburg est mort
l'année dernière de maladie… Mais un anonyme
vous envoie à vous, célèbre détective,
un appel à l'aide : pour lui, c'est un meurtre
! Aidé de votre ami policier, vous remonterez
jusqu'aux origines de la famille Hohenburg
pour retrouver le crimier.
Ça c'est pour les plus gros joueurs qui ont
envie d'être acteur de l'histoire, d'interroger
les suspects, et vous pouvez même leur mentir
ou leur réciter des versets de la Bible puisque
leurs réponses sont pas automatiques mais
faites sur-mesure par des petits enfants pakistanais
qui veulent faire des heures supp après avoir
fini de coudre des baskets.
Et en fonction des interactions, vous allez
débloquer des envois postaux d'autres indices,
des documents et des outils pour continuer
à progresser dans votre enquête.
Et après cette collection «Roman Noir»
viendront les collections Aventure, Thriller,
Horreur, et Géologie, beurre demi-sel non
fourni (bon ça c'est encore en négociations
avec eux).
Bref, si ce projet vous plaît, n'hésitez
pas à le soutenir et partager leur page Ulule,
vous avez jusqu'à fin mai pour participer
alors faut pas traîner, allez hop hop hop
!
Or donc, c'est grâce aux séismes qu'on sait
vaguement ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur de
la Terre.
Et ça, c'est grâce à une propriété magique
des ondes sismiques.
Ecoutez bien : leur vitesse dépend de la
densité du matériau qu'elles traversent.
En gros plus la roche est dense, plus les
ondes vont vite.
Donc on a planté des sismographes aux quatre
coins de la Terre et en fonction du temps
qu'une onde sismique met à faire vibrer chaque
sismographe, on peut reconstituer la vitesse
de l'onde et donc avoir une idée du matériau
qu'elle traverse.
Et c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à retracer
le trajet d'une onde sismique.
Je trouve ça très cool d'ailleurs comme
instrument : un sismographe c'est comme si
vous aviez un stylo parfaitement immobile
sur un papier posé par terre.
Si le sol tremble, le papier bouge et du coup
le stylo va faire de l'art.
Maintenant qu'on sait comment on sait à peu
près ce qu'il y a sous nos pieds, reste plus
qu'à vous y emmener.
Pour ça, je vous propose une petite expérience
de pensée.
On va faire un voyage au centre de la Terre,
c'est une idée complètement inédite.
Je devrais écrire un bouquin là-dessus.
Ah et tant qu'on est dans les idées révolutionnaires,
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à cette chaîne.
3560% des gens qui regardent mes vidéos ne
sont pas abonnés ! L'êtes-vous ? Êtes-le
! Soyez le Russe qui creuse et non pas celui
qui abandonne et qui empoisonne ses opposants
politiques.
Alors voilà, vous incarnez une onde sismique.
Vous voyagez à vélo, ça va vous parler
ça, les bobos.
Voilà donc vous chevauchez votre vélo vintage
avec un cageot à l'arrière fabriqué avec
des palettes pour transporter vos poireaux.
Vous savez, ceux que prenez à l'Amap pour
vous donner bonne conscience et que vous laissez
pourrir dans le bac à bières de votre frigo
pendant que vous allez manger au KFC comme
tout le monde.
Donc, vous devisez gaiement sur un petit chemin
caillouteux.
Ça, c'est vous qui vous enfoncez dans la
croûte terrestre.
Donc vous pédalez gaiement, vous êtes contents.
Vous êtes une onde heureuse.
Vous sentez pas qu'il se met à faire chaud
et qu'y a un cornet de roches de plus en plus
volumineux qui pèse de plus en plus lourd
au-dessus de votre tête parce que vous en
savez rien vous, vous êtes une onde ! Ça
vous touche pas, vous faites juste vibrer
les cailloux, tel Jimi Hendrix à Woodstock
durant son solo de guitare iconique dans lequel
il imite des bombardements de B-52 pendant
la guerre du Vietnam référence nécessaire.
Et la vitesse à laquelle vous pédalez, ça
représente la vitesse de l'onde.
La pression sous terre fait que la roche que
vous traversez est de plus en plus dense.
Du coup, elle est de plus en plus facile à
traverser.
Donc plus ça va, plus votre petit chemin
caillouteux est carrossable.
C'est de plus en plus facile de pédaler,
et vous allez de plus en plus vite, comme
si vous étiez en descente.
Un peu comme un youtubeur mainstream quelques
heures après avoir pris son rail.
QUAND SOUDAIN ! Vous avez parcouru à peu
près une 30aine de km et brusquement, le
petit chemin caillouteux devient une belle
piste cyclable.
Vous avez bien fait de voter écolo aux municipales.
Là en fait, vous venez de franchir une discontinuité
sismique.
C'est quand d'un coup, on change de matériau.
Vous venez de quitter la croûte et d'entrer
dans le manteau.
Foin de basalte, de gneiss ou de gabbro, maintenant
c'est le royaume de la péridotite.
Alors la profondeur de cette discontinuité
est variable.
Si vous êtes partis du fond de l'océan,
vous aurez seulement parcouru 8 km, si vous
partez d'une montagne c'est plus 60km mais
en moyenne c'est autour des 30 km.
Et cette limite croûte-manteau, elle a été
découverte en 1909 par un certain Mohorovicic.
D'où son nom, la discontinuité de Mohorovicic
ou le Moho pour les intimes.
Parce que c'est vraiment trop chiant à prononcer
le croate.
On a eu du bol avec Moho, il était à deux
doigts de s'appeler Grain de riz.
Donc on continue sur notre belle piste cyclable,
en descente, on pédale gaiement, on se sent
bien.
On se sent bien.
Et d'un coup, la piste est moins carrossable,
y'a des nids de poule.
Hidalgo démission.
Vous traversez une zone de basse vélocité,
ou LVZ, c'est l'asthénosphère.
La sphère molle.
En gros c'est une partie plus molle du manteau,
située entre 60 et 220 km de profondeur.
Y'a plein de trucs qu'on ignore sur cette
couche, on est même pas sûrs qu'elle existe
partout sur Terre.
On sait pas trop non plus pourquoi elle est
plus molle que le reste.
Mais, c'est de la roche solide, déjà.
Ce qui démonte l'idée reçue que sous nos
pieds, y'aurait des plaques tectoniques qui
surfent un océan de magma, ça c'est fake
niou.
Vous pouvez l'oublier.
En fait, la roche est tellement comprimée,
elle subit de telles pressions à ces profondeurs
que même si elle voulait être liquide, elle
ne pourrait pas.
Par contre, en remontant, là elle peut devenir
liquide puisque la pression diminue.
Et on pense que certains volcans seraient
dus justement à une remontée de panache
mantellique depuis cette asthénosphère vers
la surface.
C'est ce qui causerait ce qu'on appelle le
volcanisme de point chaud, comme à la Réunion
ou jadis peut-être même notre massif central.
Oui, le massif central était peut-être un
point chaud.
Donc on sait pas trop pourquoi cette asthénosphère
est molle.
On dit ductile pour faire chic.
Peut-être parce qu'une toute petite partie
serait effectivement fondue, 1% juste.
Ou alors qu'elle serait globalement à la
limite du point de fusion mais tellement comprimée
qu'elle reste solide, et du coup elle est
dans un état un peu intermédiaire de "je
suis solide mais j'ai envie de me comporter
quand même comme un liquide".
Mais reprenons.
Vous traversez ces nids de poule et retrouvez
maintenant une belle piste cyclable bien carrossée.
J'aurai jamais autant utilisé ce mot.
Donc, vous continuez à traverser le manteau
terrestre, vous pédalez vous pédalez sur
votre jolie piste, plus ça va plus ça descend
plus vous allez vite, plus vous vous prenez
pour un coureur du Tour de France en train
de dévaler le pic de la Truite en Normandie.
Et là, paf ! Vous vous prenez un mur de plein
fouet.
Bienvenue dans le noyau terrestre.
Ce mur c'est la limite Berlin E-Berlin W entre
le manteau et le noyau terrestre.
Enfin, vous êtes arrivés au cœur de notre
planète ! Enfin, le tour du cœur.
Et s'il vous a freinés direct, c'est parce
qu'il est liquide, ce con !
Alors il faut que je vous avoue un truc.
En fait, y'a pas un mais deux types d'ondes
sismiques qui traversent la Terre.
Les ondes P, qui sont longitudinales, et les
ondes S, qui sont cisaillantes.
Et les S sont incapables de traverser les
liquides, elles ne savent pas nager.
Du coup, si elles arrivent jusqu'au noyau
externe, elles sont coupées net dans leur
élan et elles disparaissent.
Si vous êtes une onde P par contre, vous
pouvez soit être déviée ou réfléchie
au niveau du mur et repartir d'où vous venez,
ou bien vous prenez votre courage à deux
mains, vous sautez dans la gadoue et vous
la traversez à la nage, votre vélo sur le
dos façon mud day.
Eh ouais, vous pensiez juste sortir pour faire
un tour à la friperie du coin et paf ! On
vous embarque pour un triathlon.
C'est ça, la scionce.
Là, vous avez beau être matinal, vous avez
mal.
Mais faut pas en vouloir au noyau externe
comme ça.
Ce marais, c'est à lui que vous devez la
vie.
A lui que vous devez la vie de vos parents,
de votre double souterrain, des levures de
votre bière, des mycoses entre vos doigts
de pieds, de vos amis… Ah non, ça c'est
juste grâce à votre imagination.
Eh oui, c'est grâce au noyau externe que
la Terre a un champ magnétique.
En fait, cette espèce d'étang de métal
liquide (un mélange de fer et de nickel)
boue, et en bouant comme ça il génère un
champ électrique qui lui-même génère un
champ magnétique autour de la Terre.
C'est une dynamo auto-excitée, comme on dit.
Moi-même, je ne l'ai appris qu'hier.
Et ce champ magnétique agit comme un bouclier
qui nous protège du vent solaire, des pelletées
de particules dégueulasses que le soleil
nous vomit dessus en permanence et qui sont
très nocives à la vie.
Donc dites merci à cette piscine de métal
fondu.
Et continuez à nager.
Jusqu'à ce que vous voyiez se dessiner à
l'horizon l'île aux merveilles, la destination
finale comme dirait Adolphe.
Mon cousin Adolphe, il adore voyager et surtout
quand il arrive à destination après une
rude journée sur la route.
Cette île, c'est le noyau interne.
La graine.
Elle est aussi constituée de fer et de nickel
mais cette fois, sous forme solide.
Et plus ça va, plus la Terre se refroidit
et plus la graine va grossir et prendre la
place du noyau externe.
Et quand y'aura plus du tout de noyau externe,
eh bah on sait pas ce qui va se passer pour
nos gueules et pour le champ magnétique terrestre.
Enfin sans doute qu'on sera plus là pour
le voir, mais peut-être nos doubles souterrains
si.
Cela dit, vous, vous vous arrêtez pas en
si bon chemin.
Non non ! Vous êtes une onde donc vous avez
beau être arrivés au milieu, vous continuez,
chop chop on traverse la graine, on repart
se mouiller les mollets, et hop on escalade
le mur, vous pouvez même atteindre la croûte
à nouveau si vous êtes d'humeur.
Voire rebondir là-bas et repartir dans l'autre
sens… Eh oui, traverser la rue ça vous
suffit pas, vous vous traversez carrément
la planète.
Ca c'est l'esprit français.
Et voilà donc comment on sait ce qui se cache
dans les entrailles de notre bonne vieille
Terre sans l'ouvrir en deux.
En l'écoutant vibrer.
L'histoire ne dit pas si ça marche aussi
pour voir l'intérieur des gens atteints de
la maladie de Parkinson.
Et le pire c'est qu'on a vraiment juste une
vague idée de ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
de la Terre, y'a encore plein de subtilités
qu'on continue de découvrir au fur et à
mesure.
Par exemple que le manteau n'est pas du tout
homogène, on découvre des régions de basse
vélocité (comme l'asthénosphère dont on
a parlé, les nids de poule).
On en a trouvé une énorme sous le Pacifique
à l'interface noyau-manteau.
Donc en fait la piste cyclable est moins parfaitement
carrossable que je vous l'ai fait croire et
certains chemins sont moins sympa que d'autres.
Des chercheurs pensent même qu'on y trouverait
les vestiges d'une ancienne planète aujourd'hui
disparue, celle que la Terre aurait percutée
pendant sa prime jeunesse pour aboutir à
la création de la Lune.
Rien que ça.
Un peu comme si on avait absorbé notre jumeau
siamois dans le ventre de notre mère et qu'on
se baladait avec ses organes à l'intérieur.
Et figurez-vous que ce qu'on a fait là, des
chercheurs sont en train de le faire aussi
sur Mars ! En 2018, les géologues de l'Institut
de physique du globe ont déposé un sismomètre
sur Mars, qui s'appelle Seis.
Et son but c'est justement de comprendre l'intérieur
de la planète Mars grâce aux séismes.
Car oui, il y a aussi des séismes sur Mars.
Et aussi par exemple de comprendre d'où venait
le champ magnétique martien qui a disparu.
Bref, plein de questions sans réponse.
Un sentiment qu'exprime pleinement ce proverbe
traditionnel russe : miasa.
Merci aux tipeurs et surtout, bonne année.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo allez voir
la chaîne de Sous Nos Pieds qui cause de
géologie de manière vachement poétique
sa race et que cette chaîne gagne à être
connue.
Je le remercie d'ailleurs d'avoir bien voulu
relire le script de cette présente vidéo.
Et si vous êtes riches, n'oubliez pas de
soutenir le projet de jeu d'enquête de ma
potesse et aussi j'ai ouvert ma boutique en
ligne si ça vous dit d'y jeter un œil.
Enfin mes boutiques, y'en a une sur Utip et
une sur Teespring.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, vous pouvez aller
voir cette dégustation de bouillabaisse ou
ce défilé de manchots en salopette.